[Music]
the the biggest passion i had coming
into this talk
was the ability to make sure
as many people as possible even if it
was just one or two
kind of left with the notion of how do i
become more blindly consumer-centric
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
how are you doing today i'm incredibly
well how are you
i'm good thanks absolutely amazing to
have you with us
i'm super excited i'll let you get
started
awesome well everybody first and
foremost um
i really want to do as much q as
possible because i think the details
matter
so i'll pontificate here a little bit
create some observations that i'm seeing
in the universe
but what i really want to focus on is
the q a so please
submit them um you know really at the
end of the day
we what i've been spending a lot of time
on is
self-awareness observations
um leaning into things that
are obvious to you
around you what i mean by that is as i
understood the profile of
the individuals on the other side of
this when you're
in a kind of b to b to c environment
there's a lot that goes into that you
know i i live in that world
actually actively myself with
vaynermedia
for all the garyvee content out there i
i operate a daily business
um that has 1500 people globally around
the world that is servicing clients
and for a lot of you you're building
applications
on you know and front-facing web
realities
for us a lot of it is content and media
and creative
all for everyone involved to create a
result whether that is a donation or
more likely a sale um b2b2c is a very
intriguing game because you've got to
find the balance between
delivering what you believe uh
while having a human on the other side
that is making decisions for their
business
as you being a provider and then finally
there's the consumer at the end i was
giving a lot of thought to this talk and
also knowing
that he had some pretty big icons
chatting here like seth
uh i said what do i want to narrow
in on that might provide value that
might be a compliment to everybody else
who's
speaking and so one thing that i've
observed over the last several years and
and me and the organization here talked
a lot about you know positioning this as
adapt or die and really what that really
just stands for
in my perspective when they brought to
the forefront is the reality of
adjusting to the reality of the consumer
which is really
at the end of the day over the last 20
plus years
something that i spend the majority of
my time thinking about you know i
i think i think about why it comes so
natural to me
to deploy really at the end of the day
humility the humility of like regardless
of what
i would like it to be regardless of what
has happened
yesterday the the concept of you're only
as good as your last at-bat
is very real to me the consumer behavior
shifts are very real on a daily basis
on a yearly basis on a decade basis you
start adding elements like what we've
just all gone through
it changes patterns it changes
consumptions it changes perspectives
and so a couple things that i really
wanted to focus on number one
in the very micro of what i know most of
this audience does for a living
i believe the single biggest thing that
one can be is religious about the
current behavior of the consumer let me
explain what i mean by that
your capacity to understand
how people are navigating from a ui ux
standpoint
on a website on a mobile device what is
the actual
consumer behavior at this moment both
in the easy part math you know the quant
the data is so supportive in in a
meeting that you would have with the
client but then also the qual
just understanding behaviors on the
consumer side of like
shifts or leaning into things like your
intuition
or your pattern recognition of things
that the project you just did
and seeing that the site is not
converting as well as
you and your uh client anticipated and
the question becomes
why even if the traffic is eliminated as
the excuse because
what's happening on the site is not
acting the way
that you'd like it to obviously i don't
have to explain to this group
the ios 14 update is going to impact a
lot of our clients
in the retargeting and things that
nature so
you know the reality is is that
things are always moving and i think a
obsession from this group an obsession
around the actual consumer behavior will
always be the greatest leverage you know
for me
um and yes i'm glad this banner's up
please get into the specific questions
because that's
my mindset and mood these days but i
want to get into those details
but to me the thing that has been very
fascinating over the last 15
13 years running vayner is how many
people dig in to their religion
uh to how it was what they're most
comfortable with
uh over recommending tactics that
they're comfortable because they
understand it
even though the consumer has moved on
from those tactics so
for me the the biggest passion i had
coming into this talk
was the ability to make sure
as many people as possible even if it
was just one or two
kind of left with the notion of how do i
become more blindly consumer-centric
and how do i fight for
the customer in my b2b
conference meeting in those rooms in
those rooms how do i
fight for the reality of consumer
behavior
over my selfish wants
of what i know how to do over and over
blindly in my sleep and it's easier
the client pushing me in a direction
that might be against
our beliefs so one of one of the things
that i helped one of my devshop
friends do several years ago that has
been much
maybe even more fruitful for him than i
thought he hired this incredible um
consumer insights uh executive that i
was very fond of she worked for me for a
little while moved on wanted to go to
something smaller
and it's been remarkable to me and it's
probably the inspiration for why i start
my opening rant
with this subject matter how much that
has factored into the growth of their
business
the end of the day the consumer is so
important you have to clearly have
passions
you have to clearly understand what you
stand for you have to
have a sense of what you believe but
please have the humility
for the consumer um the other the other
thing that i think
one really needs to think about is so
many people here have won
on jumping on the wave of a technology
shift
right you were first to move on websites
you were the first to move on sms you
were the first to move on you know
whatever it might be
um i spoke about it very briefly in the
context of what's a consumer doing
so that you can provide that service for
your customer but then for your own
business
uh one of the things that i've been also
observing quite a bit
is the stagnant nature of many providers
many b2b2c uh executives
on their hesitation to adopt
new capabilities adding things
to their repertoire offering more
services
um this whole innovation doesn't have
feelings for any of us thing
really really matters to me and i'm a
very big believer of that
and what whether that is
what is in the air a little bit right
now we're in extremely early stages and
there's a lot of mockery a lot of bad
executions but you know very clearly
from a development standpoint web 3 is
brewing and whether it's 1995 or 1999 in
the scheme of the internet revolution
for
web3 the way websites interact with
decentralized servers is something that
should be on many people's minds in here
even if you're not looking to provide
that service or
or expand or hire into
web 3 development just getting
what i call the appetizer or where
there's smoke there's fire i play a lot
in smoke land
have my have my hands and different
things just to get a little sense just
to get a little sense
um and and then when it feels like it's
ready for prime time
you start to productize it you know for
me
you start to talk about it whatever it
might be
and so i think a word that has
emerged for me quite a bit in
self-reflection and as i
mature and go through my process i'm
surprised
how much curiosity has been a factor
in my overall human success let alone
some of my business uh you know
successes
and excitements and so i always go into
a a talk like this
with this consumer profile by the way
that that deer is exciting me that's
popping up on the screen i'm not sure
what that is but
i'm very excited about that uh uh
curiosity is incredibly practical
is how i see it in my mind these days
it's that appetizer and smoke thing that
i just referenced
is something i'd like to challenge or
inspire or
create the seed of debate for every
individual on the other side of the
screen of
are you genuinely pushing yourself to
learn
or to at least taste or most of all what
has been probably got me there was i was
surprised how many people
were dismissive over the last 12 13
months it's been a very
incredible time you know in a weird way
zooms and things like this have allowed
me to scale human interaction
right the inefficiencies of travel or
things that nature i've been able to
have a lot of interactions during this
um this period of covid
and something that struck me both from
fortune 500 land
startup land vc land nft land just an
incredible
passion for no we're dismissing
which i understand grabbing a lot of
insecurities a lot of other
variables that lead to that but this
audience i think actually
has an incredible vulnerability
when i think about b2b2c um
to not stay curious because another
service provider
has the ability to out innovate
and then commoditize what you bring to
the table i'm a very very big fan of
putting myself out of business before
somebody else does it for me
and so you know i i would say we're in a
moment of
transition of consumer behavior in
how they consume the internet that will
continue to flow
whether it's things a decade out or
somewhere within a decade
like vr and oculus whether it's whether
it's just
the way people behave in mobile this
industry again building sites
all of you all of you can
have incredible context to what i'm
speaking about when the world really
went
more mobile native there were so many
dev shops that
just didn't move quickly enough to
understanding how to design or ui
in a mobile environment and many fell by
the wayside so
you know just a level of curiosity
you know if you're in the e-commerce
element
if you look at the advancements of
what's going on
you know within social shopping are you
in a place where you can develop
social profiles that are more likely to
convert than let's say
on top of a wordpress infrastructure so
these are all things that
i think need real real debate with
oneself but i think
the overall arching thing for me is
i love i love these last two decades and
they continue to play out the same
way with different nuances these are
substantial shifts in human behavior the
internet
it was substantial you're you're about
to hear at some point from one of the
great thinkers and ogs of early internet
behavior
i think i think i'm right about this
seth sold one of his companies early on
to yahoo like
there was so much going on there and it
was so early and there was so much
that had was assumed much of it did play
out
in different timing than a lot of us
thought much didn't play out
and i think everything is now compounded
there's so much more
infrastructure the the railroad tracks
the roads they're built
and so now we're on to that next phase
and i think for a lot of this group
this next five years is going to be
defined
on how consumer-centric
how curious they were to evolve
their products and services how much
were they able to
adjust quote unquote with the times
i'll spend a few more minutes on one
other subject matter and then we'll get
into the q a
to make everything that i just said roll
from like a strategy and leadership
capability
there's another incredible nuance which
is another
uh word i'm incredibly passionate about
is continuity
you know i think for a lot of you if
you're picking up on what i'm putting
down
an incredible thing to to really reflect
on
is how you're leading so much
i've come to realize as well another fun
observation during this
incredible opportunity to think um
continuity
you know some of you may know i'm a very
big new york jets fan
and i love that team and and in football
there's something called an offensive
line because i know this is
international crowd in the nfl is not
necessarily an international
sport but there's these five gentlemen
who protect the quarterback
and uh the data is remarkably powerful
on teams that are able to keep those
same five offensive linemen
uh year after year for a period of time
and i think about that quite a bit when
i think about organizations
how structured are you as a leader
on being obsessed around retention and
leaning into the emotional intelligence
that is required to manage people
individually and
reverse engineer their ambitions whether
that is financial or
credibility and and fame or awareness
uh challenges you know i think that's
something that people
really need to reflect on because to be
able to have the time
and the mental capacity as a business to
innovate
uh you must be in a position where
you're
you're i i call innovating and jumping
into this
hunting you know finding right you're
going out and hunting
if you're farming isn't strong back home
you're going to be in trouble and so i
i think one little nuance on this
framework of
really leaning in to the truth of
consumer behavior today and then
allowing yourself to
innovate your products and services and
then uphold that
in the rooms with your clients it's
going to require great farming and so i
ask
all the leaders to have a good sense of
what their relationships are with the
number one two
three four people in their organization
uh how deep does that number go down do
you have an understanding of what
motivates them and do you believe in the
continuity
that then will allow you to go hunt
while they all farm and so
a couple thoughts uh this morning this
evening depending on where you're uh
we're watching this from but i'm
incredibly humbled
uh to be a part of this i uh i
i really do think that there is
a very interesting turn
uh brewing and i want to make sure that
everyone here is
popping their head out of their
day-to-day minutia and really
understanding
what products they should be building on
top of this how should they be thinking
about it
um and how do they put themselves in a
position to succeed
thank you okay
thanks gary that was an incredibly
interesting
opening for us and i think all web
creators know exactly what you're
talking about right this ever changing
environment things are moving
really quickly in the web and we we have
to do our best to keep up but in the
same time stay innovative
stay curious and let's move to questions
please okay so um our first question is
what content should i be creating on
social media as a web designer to stay
relevant and set myself apart from
the competition currently in the
day-to-day
place there's a couple places that
there's two places i'm incredibly
passionate about
uh linkedin and tick-tock and here's why
over the last 15 years just playing in
these spaces these platforms go through
very similar
trajectories where you have this early
group on them
if it's destined to become a bigger
platform and it's just good
old-fashioned supply and demand
a very simple principle there's more
demand on them there's more people
consuming content on them
than people are creating from a content
standpoint right
and so what happens is early movers
especially if they're able to provide
value whether that is information
escapism you know entertainment is
obviously major on these platforms but
there's
i always tell people there's always a
place for expertise
uh understanding of a topic domain
knowledge
and so the reason i like tick-tock and
linkedin for
this crew is it's a biz dev portal right
on tick-tock you have an incredible
environment
of independent creators who are
making a real living at this point
through brand deals for
selling merchandise and as they mature
their website their web presence
really matters and especially when you
get into
uh accessories and merchandising and so
putting out
content that is contextually native
which doesn't mean you have to dance
and create the web developer jiggle
it's more about putting out content that
you actually feel
brings value and then maybe doing some
subtle editing
within the app and then obviously on
linkedin you know linkedin has been
an incredibly interesting one for me it
was
for almost a decade a utility right it
was a place where people really used it
for getting jobs resumes all that kind
of reality we all know recruiting
over the last half decade maybe a little
bit more it has emerged as a meaningful
you know content hub and there's an
incredible amount of consumption on it
and enormous amounts of
b to b decision making happens in it and
again
content creation is about um
is about self-awareness as a matter of
fact this is great to have seth here
today seth is one of
my favorite people to read he has an
incredible skill set to be able to write
and make you consume it and enjoy it
that is
that was not my destiny you know i i
don't have that skill
my my comfort zone was one video you
know and
and that was a comfort zone for me
what's amazing about
linkedin is whether it's the written
word whether it's video or an emerging
thing that i'm seeing from people
is they have the gift of gab they like
to do the talking but for some
unfortunate reason
they have a level of insecurity of being
on video which you know
comes in many shapes and sizes and um i
think that uh
the recording of an audio clip and then
posting it in a linkedin environment is
an opportunity for many
even when you get a random great thought
or an observation of
things that people should be thinking
about so linkedin and tick tock have the
organic reach to allow everybody who's
watching here
who doesn't have any audience that a
meaningful piece of content that was
destined to get a little awareness
becomes a biz dev portal those are two
places i would focus the most on the
supply and demand of attention
okay thanks gary i mean i do like the
idea of a web creator jig but i hear
what you're saying that we don't need to
go
we don't need to go that route i'm sorry
that's a very important point
i i think people are intimidated by tick
tock in a lot of ways which is why i say
that
on the flip side god willing
the web creator jig could ridiculously
for that's what's so ridiculous about
tick-tock that
makes no sense that wouldn't be my
betting horse and yet
if somebody said to me that was destined
to hit
i'd be like yeah that's just the way
that platform works and so i think
not being in no culture is very
important for content creation
and i think that's something everyone
here should think about
okay that's definitely a good one good
piece of advice there
and i i really love this question
because i think it's something that we
talk a lot
about a lot at elementor okay so i'm
going to read out client behavior
and consumer behavior can be very
different how do you navigate the divide
between the two
brilliant question it's a great question
and it completely affirms what i tried
to start this talk with right
this is why i think you know the that
whole
i genuinely believe this statement
whoever is closest to the consumer
wins it's just so darn obvious in many
ways
and and in our b2b to see realities for
all of us
it's also true it has been you know i
came into advertising especially madison
envy with such blind eyes
genuinely knew nothing and what what
guided us and gave us an incredible
start
was we were just blindly
consumer-centric this is what's
happening with the customer
this is what's happening with the
customer we also had an appetite and a
willingness
to not win the client and so a lot of
you know obviously as vayner's gone to
where it's gone i've had a lot of people
who've reached out i love jamming with
people in my own industry
trying to help and i i speak to that and
i
and the thing that i'm worried about
that question is we love to blame the
client
we love it but the reality is that bad
behavior
or that behavior is completely
predicated based on the line in the sand
that we're all willing to draw
right and so i highly recommend dying on
your own sword
i love when we don't win a pitch when we
said the truth because it comes around
three years later five years later
so this was why i spent a lot of time
you know i don't know if you can see
this i got a little bit of goosebumps
i'm really happy right now because i
really wanted to
think like you know you don't have a lot
of time you want to bring value i'm
obsessed with that more and more every
day
i genuinely believe that every hour this
audience spends
on trying to truly understand what
customers are doing
pays unbelievable dividends
throughout their organization and
ultimately in this exact question which
i think is the elephant in a room for so
many
uh it will give you the conviction and
the confidence
to draw that line you'll start to get
intoxicated
when you you're going to lose let me
give you a news alert because i live it
you're going to lose 8 out of 10 because
of it
because a lot of people on the other
side want to go with the easy and the
historical
when you win the two you win them on
your terms you do better work
it feels better and it builds momentum
and that's that's what i dream for a lot
of people in this call
awesome thanks for that and we actually
have a live question
coming in so i'm going to activate the
video
if i can
um it's it's it's it's live so we're
going to carry on with some more
questions
no worries i'm going to i'm gonna keep
reading um
all right so our next question is
um oh i'm ha
i hear that we do have the live
questions i'm excited for this one
so ah
[Laughter]
what an honor seth how are you it's good
to see you man and
i've just been i've just been sponging
up everything you've been putting down
thank you this is one of the
great moments of web history right here
on the screen
and here we are back again um so you
just answered my last question but the
next one i have for you is this
you are really clearly continually
living on the frontier
and dancing with the future but you've
been at this ever since the wine store
in new jersey
and the question i'm going to ask on
behalf of web creators is
what's the one thing not the next big
thing but the old
and still raining big thing that they
don't get yet
just let us know that's a great question
thank you so
first of all it's just really good to
see you i hope you're well i would like
to go for a walk
yeah let's i'll i'll text you out there
thank you so much it's so nice to see
you
um that
that the mix of math and intuition
is a very important relationship i think
the thing that is allowed you know
you don't know what that feels like and
i think i've i i hope i've made it clear
every time we've interacted
my incredible admiration for you for you
to say
continue it means the world to me
because i admire you and i think
what what the old thing which is the new
thing
it's always the same game which is
there's a level of intuition
there's so much pattern recognition i
had even by the time i got into liquor
store you know you say
since the wine store so much of my
lemonade
sports card shoveling snow as i get
older
a little more wiser you start realizing
oh wow
even that was the pattern recognition
that helped me you know with the wine
stuff so
quickly which then i built on it's
it's having the humility and the
conviction
in balance the gray and the black and
white the math
because because if it was one or the
other it it just
you know that's what where we see
failure you see too many people using
data
as a look back which is why they don't
see the next thing which is why enormous
companies fail right
uh and then you have other people that
are a little bit too off the reservation
on
it's all like they completely don't have
you know they have these incredible
intuitive feelings
but they're not willing to look at truth
in their face
and take a a back step and so
especially for these web creators you
know
i i was very taken aback by so many i
met so many smart friends who had web
shops
who just genuinely dismissed this set
you know these were my first rodeos
so i hadn't been around smart people who
were blindly
blindly pushing against something that
was so obvious because they
either were tired and didn't want to i
have a lot of empathy for it they were
tired and they want to learn a new craft
they there was a million they were
making too much money and they didn't
want the thing to change
you know i always tell people i don't
want tick tock to happen i've got
instagram figured out
i don't want instagram to happen i had
twitter figured out like you know i
don't have this great
want for these new things to happen they
become work
every time but but i but i know that
there's no shot for me to be successful
in what i do without it so
i would say the relationship between
intuition and math
and not over indexing one or the other
and
and if it doesn't come natural one or
the other surrounding yourself with
teammates
that is just a tried and true old thing
thank you sir keep leaving thank you
thank you my friend we'll talk to you
okay that was a huge treat for us gary i
hope
if you okay you're down with the
surprise and says
thank you so much and we'll see you a
bit later um
okay so i'll move on to the next
question for you gary
another great one done or perfect is
is always done better than perfect and
is always perfect
done the people out there are curious
about what you think
perfect is an insecurity now in web
development
it has to work right but
i find that people that are in love with
perfection are using it
as an excuse to not be judged
uh to procrastinate to
to create leverage that they're
perfectionists
around the others to give them control
so i'm a big fan of dunn
big fan okay
i really really really love that answer
i feel like you were speaking directly
to me so i'm sure it's resonating with
other people as well
um next question what's the most
important
post-covered trend apps social media
what do you think what's what's the most
important trend
the macro trend is eliminating friction
right you have a lot of people in their
40s to 80s that got accustomed to less
friction
right they they know what people let's
say under 40
have natively been comfortable with and
those are arbitrary numbers i'm 45 and
i'm very in this but like
um so i think the trend is eliminating
friction
so whether that's last mile delivery
whether it's a million other things
i couldn't push people enough to
in their web development create
experiences that
eliminate friction like nobody wants a
big banner pop-up
to sign up for the email even though it
converts well
but how can you do it better because it
eliminates a little friction people that
can
advance things uh to eliminate friction
will be the big winner so
lack of friction is a huge consumer want
it's always been
and it's been accelerated with covet
because people got into convenience
uh realities in their day-to-day
okay love it and next question
what is the best way to get leads when
you have a low budget for marketing
we're really all all over today loads of
different directions for you
linkedin linkedin organic content
it's you will i'm telling you everyone
you will be blown away
you could have no followers you cannot
even have a linkedin account
and you can create one post your first
post of three
uh uh let me give you a good one you're
in the mood you're a good you're a good
writer
21 things to think about in 2021 when
designing your website
that's where you title it you write it
you'd be shocked
how many leads come from things like
that but you got to stay with it it's
like working out
the first exercise is not going to get
it done keep chipping away at it
okay i think this is a great follow-up
kind of because it's this next question
says when you first started vaynermedia
how did you go about signing up your
first clients without a portfolio
from what i understand they were quite
big accounts too
they were i had a little bit of an
advantage because i did what i'm telling
everybody here to do
i was creating twitter content a lot of
it
and had built up a little bit of a
notoriety
for being right or being ahead of things
and that led to you know campbell's and
and pepsi to to consider us to give us a
shot
and so um the nhl so
it was it was my content that led to
relationships that led to business and
i believe everybody here can do it too
and linkedin and tick tock are
incredibly organic
places right now and one needs to be
figuring that out
okay great and next question three
recommendations to better understand
the consumer uh
listen listen listen and let me let me
explain by that
discords reddit twitter
instagram explore uh
those four places are incredible join
discords
join reddit join
use hashtags and look at trending topics
use the explore page
spend your time in communities to
extract consumer insights
read read and contribute join facebook
groups i think facebook groups are very
sneaky and good
local ones subject matter ones aka if
you're
a web developer in mexico city join the
mexico city entrepreneur
facebook group subject matters
you know join small business group
small business is always need your work
so
that kind of stuff okay great
and this is a good one also because you
you have talked a lot about
linkedin twitter social media so where
do you see the role of websites in the
world of social media
well they're still incredibly important
i think social media's job a lot of
times is to get people to websites
um and i think websites carry incredible
amount of weight
i do think with social media a lot of
people
use web social media sites to do what
their website used to do for them
so there has been some fragmentation but
i could never imagine not having
websites for anything i'm doing as of
right now and
when that becomes a day then i'll adjust
but i think websites
matter tremendously i don't i don't i
see a lot of influencers who have 20 30
40 million followers
and have a very shitty website or don't
even have one and it baffles me it's a
huge missed opportunity to collect
opportunity
and um and that's why i like tick tock
for a lot of people here
i think they could go viral as a web
developer on tick tock
which would then lead to people dming
them and asking them to build their
websites for them
okay cool i think coming from someone
like you we're all feeling
a bit calmer now that websites are here
today
um so next question how do you recruit
team members
we're at scale now we're almost 1500
people so there's a lot of word of mouth
we've also built a big reputation um but
in the beginning
and this was why i keep pushing
everybody here to create content
it's about creating content because
when you do a nice post on linkedin
that's smart
people are going to go to your linkedin
profile they're going to click your
website you're going to have a hiring
link on your website
and people are going to fill out that
form content is
the it's the hunter your website is the
farmer we need to bring them there
so put out good content on linkedin by
the way
jab jab jab right hook one of my most
successful you know
hooks put out content put out content
put out content for them 21 things to
think about
five good rules how to navigate ios 14
just good thinking the things all of you
know
but then maybe the tenth post on
linkedin is i'm hiring somebody
hi everybody i'm hiring somebody and
boom it just
sends it that way so you know i think
think about that stuff
cool so this is a great question we have
a 16 year old watching and they want
some tips for how they
start a business you just did
you know what's amazing about it is you
don't have to overthink it you have to
decide what you're selling
are you good at selling it meaning are
you good at excuse me are you good at
delivering it are you proud of what
you're selling
if it's web development that's amazing
um if it's nft art that's amazing and
then you've got to go out and build
awareness
through content content is commercials
commercials built coca-cola and
mcdonald's and
they'll build you too uh you just have
to be self-aware
and put out more content than you think
because those are your at-bats and
that's how i see it
okay cool so we're in a we're in a
content space
so the next question is can you talk
about the right blend
of entertainment versus educational
content
i think that's very much uh
person-to-person thing i think you need
to
be who you are so if you're inherently
you know i think for me i blend
my personality into my information
content which i think is why it works
i think that um for a lot of people
they think there's a right answer and
there's not
it could be 88 12 it could be 50 50 it
could be 12
88 lean into what you are
because all of it works
awesome so next question any tips for
getting through the hardest part of your
business
the grind
for me it's hard to answer this question
because i enjoy the grind
because i like i like it like i for me
running a business is like playing golf
or
sailing or rock climbing
for a lot of people those are their
favorite hobbies and they like the hard
part just as much as the
accomplishment that's how i see business
i see it as a
as a hobby and so for me i love my
process
for everybody who's thinking about this
you got to ask yourself how much do you
love it are you doing it for the money
or are you doing it because you can't
help it you just like it so much
and i think that's where you start
figuring out the grind part
i also think just putting things in
perspective i think that people
value money too much value
um business success too much i think if
you put business in its place
and realize that it's important but
not the most important thing in the
world
that the health of who you love is if
you can put it into an actual
perspective i think that really helps
yep i have to agree with you that
perspective is everything
and so i guess maybe this one you don't
have an answer for but
what was the moment that almost had you
quit and how did you get
over that hump i've never had that
moment
you know i don't want to make up stories
i just haven't
um it's just uh which i'm very
fortunate i've i've had
challenges in the micro what i would
maybe
micro quitting right um and i've handled
them two ways
sometimes i've got i have stopped
sometimes i've shut down companies
divisions and and i don't judge myself
i'm i'm trying the best i can and
sometimes i fail
and i'm okay with that other times i
just liked it so much that i persevered
through those challenging days and found
myself on the other side of it feeling
very accomplished that i got thrilled
great and how can a freelance designer
close high tickets i'm having problems
closing deals the first calls go
incredibly well
but once the price goes out i'm having
trouble closing the deals
to me i'm a big fan of more at bats
right create focus more on getting more
of the meetings
like have you had eight first amazing
meetings and then went oh for eight
well then get 52 opening meetings
uh humility i think some people
i like to ebb and flow with my fees
whether that's speaking
vaynermedia you know if you're a little
cold and you're not
having success you lower the price
if you start building back up you raise
the price um
more more first meetings and having
humility to lower the price for a period
of time
when you're in a cold streak
okay great um all right the next
question
gary how do you see the future of web
is no coding gonna take down the coding
i'm not sure you know i don't i don't
like answering things i don't fully know
i think that um i have a tough time
believe that no coding is
so omni and and and so at scale that it
affects the majority of people
that are on here right now so
i i do think coding on top of
decentralized servers is something a lot
of people should be thinking about
i am bullish on web3 so that's that's
what i'm seeing
great how can i keep my social media
content hot
and interesting there's just so much out
there
by not worrying about that you know you
can't worry about competition
in that scenario the the most
simple way to win that game is to
continue to challenge yourself to be
authentically you and show all parts of
you
you know i show that i'm a jets fan i
talk about liking
bone broth i i talk about wine i talk
about
many things and so i think too many
people are too limited
yes you're a web developer but you're a
million other things and maybe it is
your deep passion of fishing
and your knowledge about fishing and
your fishing content that actually leads
to more
web contracts than even your web
uh developer content and i think too
many people don't show enough sides of
themselves
okay i think this is probably going to
feed into the next question which is
for a new web design and digital agency
how would you suggest to compete and
stand out against companies that have 15
plus years experience
and always seem to be one step ahead
content on linkedin about things you're
seeing put out your best
information for free like i do which
attracts intrigue
and then have as many first meetings as
possible and like the freelancer have
the humility
to price accordingly to the reality of
your situation
i was a very accomplished businessman
when i started vaynermedia and i was
selling my services for nothing
i was getting paid more to give a speech
for an hour than i was getting paid to
work on an account per month
and i was okay with that because i had
the humility and patience to build the
company
awesome those are definitely themes that
we hear coming from you
a lot which is great consistency you
said it earlier
um what are the most common mistakes one
could make in a startup
what are ways to avoid them spending
more money than you have
i find people very funny with their
monies
uh early on and again back to
consistency
being fancy when you're in the beginning
as a startup
you need to just get to the next day and
a little more humility around pricing
and servicing
is required while not compromising what
you're about and what you believe in
okay all right well we're coming up to
time so i think we have time for one
more question which i'm going to ask now
and how do you discover new consumers
trends
how do you avoid a sunk cost fallacy
um i just listen we said it earlier
i spend all my time looking at what the
consumers are actually doing on these
social platforms reading reading reading
i'm in the
i do you know such a loud mouth but the
reality is i'm listening so much more
than i'm talking
you just see the videos where i'm
talking after all the listening so
just spending a lot more time in these
communities
and and observing people's beliefs
awesome i'm kind of blown away
thanks so much gary for being with us we
really appreciate it
thank you everybody i hope you enjoy
seth as as i know you will and we'll
talk soon bye everyone
bye gary thanks so much youtube what's
up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon